dites ce que vous avez à dire
c'est nous qu'on a souffert c'est nous
qu'on a souffert c'est tout
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
désolé
sans l'impact de l'activité physique sur
le corps qu'un professeur de PS a mesuré
et pesé des collégiens de 6e on faisait
Camille les parents en colère à aucun
moment un prof n'en a le droit on était
dans un jugement immédiat sans
discrétion et cela a pu générer des
moqueries certains enfants même été
choqués par ce moment ça a été
traumatisant pour elle mon enfant avait
honte ma fille est rentré en pleurs et
c'est n'importe quoi en fait à l'école
on est là pour apprendre et donc c'est
très bien de peser par exemple au début
pour montrer pour apprendre que le sport
et la bonne alimentation permet de
perdre du poids parce qu'on sait
aujourd'hui qu'il y a plein de jeunes
qui sont en obésité que les jeunes
mangent très mal donc il y a absolument
aucun problème pardon c'est l'heure de
la visite médicale qu'on est pesée par
un médecin personne ne voit
effectivement c'est un vrai traumatisme
pour ceux qui sont un petit peu en
surpoids ou même ceux qui comme moi
petit étaient très maigre c'était un
vrai complexe avec tous tes copains
autour qui voient le poids et tout quand
on connaît la méchanceté les enfants
qu'est-ce qui lui a pris à ce prof de PS
de peser des gens comme ça on te met une
étiquette si tu fais 80 kilos tu vas
être le boudin de la classe c'est
horrible alors c'est pas non il faut pas
la sanctionner c'est normal si c'est
grave
c'est une maladresse on va dire une
maladresse moi je trouve ça très grave
en fait pour faire de la prévention pour
lutter contre l'obésité mais les
problèmes de poids ça ne se règle pas en
un claquement d'oie c'est des problèmes
qui sont plus profonds parfois qui
nécessitent un suivi psychologique et
pardon mais c'est ultra frontal de peser
des élèves à l'école on sait que l'école
ça génère des moqueries voire du
harcèlement que tout le monde a saute
des élèves qui sont en surpoids au
contraire qui sont trop maigre c'est
extrêmement grave de faire ça et je
pense qu'il doit être sanctionné je te
donnerai pas la parole sur le sujet mais
je suis entré d'avoir ton avis mais je
te laisse te préparer pour les gens dans
les prisons les gens dans les prisons
sont des citoyens Daniel Riolo est-il
allé trop loin je te laisse voilà je te
laisse tranquille on sera sur tes côtes
tout à l'heure t'inquiète pas tu emmerde
pas la profite prendre des chewing-gum
moi un petit verre ramenez-lui un petit
truc voilà
comment on peut laisser deux personnes
dans une telle détresse pour rappel ils
affirme être contraint de vivre dans
leur camping-car de 10 mètres carrés
depuis plus de 2 ans à cause d'une
locataire qui occupe illégalement leur
maison on a pu ami de rien elle nous
brûle notre vie des propos auquel Nadia
l'occupant de leur logement a réagi hier
soir
illégal du logement du couple de
retraite à Marseille
on attend tous d'avoir votre version
vous voulez vous voulez inoccupante
illégal pour
pour moi en fait je suis locataire
encore aujourd'hui
puisqu'il y a des un appel
en novembre
j'ai demandé des délais et aujourd'hui
je suis là pour m'exprimer alors donc si
un appel en novembre ce qui veut dire
que donc on aura passé la trêve
hivernale donc vous allez pouvoir passer
jusqu'au 15 mars dans la dans la maison
on est dans une folie médiatique n'est
pas qu'elle n'a jamais connu c'est très
perturbant pour elle et ça lui cause
aujourd'hui véritablement beaucoup de
soucis vous travaillez à Nadia voilà
vous avez une fille deux enfants deux
enfants une fille qui les deux habitent
avec vous non d'accord vous avez votre
fille qui habite avec vous oui tout à
fait 15 ans exactement aujourd'hui on
n'est pas venu se cacher si on voulait
se cacher on serait pas venu sur votre
plateau on serait pas venu sur les
bitures le plus populaire de France
finalement donc elle habite ce logement
depuis 5 ans maintenant contrairement à
ce que j'ai entendu sur les réseaux je
suis dans diverses émissions il n'y a
pas de problématique à la base de loyer
impayés et d'ailleurs on a déjà vous a
produit une pièce aujourd'hui que vous
allez peut-être montrer dans lequel
l'agence de location d'accord qui est en
réalité le seul interlocuteur de Nadia
ça veut dire que Nadia les Hipp ne les
connaît pas elle ne les a jamais
rencontré le bail a été fait avec une
agence immobilière les loyers sont payés
auprès de l'agence immobilière les
quittances sont délivrés par l'agence
immobilière les éprouveriens finalement
elle est physiquement il y a 48 heures
sur les médias non moi en fait je ne
fonctionne pas qu'avec l'agence j'ai en
fait j'ai payé des frais d'agence j'ai
toujours payé mes loyers ils étaient
prélevés j'ai juste au révoqué au mois
d'août tout simplement en fait tout
simplement le loyer à partir d'où alors
question que je vous pose vous pouvez me
dire non vous pouvez me dire non je me
sens pas de leur parler ce soir est-ce
que vous voulez avoir une entrevue avec
Pierre et Marie
Monsieur Madame Garcia en fait je vous
connais pas du tout vous m'avez fait
confiance à travers votre agence
d'accord
simplement aujourd'hui en fait je suis
venue m'expliquer m'excuser puisque ça a
pris des proportions telles que j'ai
tout essayé avec l'agence moi je ne
savais pas tout ce que vous d'accord
vous êtes dans vos droits d'accord moi
je suis locataire moi j'ai fait
confiance à une agence tout simplement
d'accord tout simplement Nadia est-ce
que aujourd'hui vous êtes prêtes à
quitter
le logement oui ça fait longtemps que
j'essaye de le quitter vous savez donc
vous essayez de trouver un nouveau
logement c'est ça ça fait longtemps je
pense que l'addition de Nadia est prise
elle va vouloir quitter le logement et
elle veut quitter ce logement moi j'ai
envie oui mais Nadia elle va pas le
quitter il faut qu'elle oublie Nadia
est-ce qu'on peut nous avec la
production vous aider pendant un mois
pour que vous puissiez vous retourner et
pour que Pierre et Marie puisse entrer
dans leur appartement dès demain ou des
samedi maximum est-ce que c'est possible
on a déjà peur aussi avoir cette
position qui est la sienne et qui est
citoyenne que de dire j'attends l'appel
bien sûr d'accord
l'appel il est pas suspensif alors la
peine n'est pas suspensive forcé de
constater qu'à ce jour France public
n'est pas venu la déloger c'est ça oui
donc oui c'est sûr c'est vrai qu'elle
peut dire voilà oui on peut dire
j'attends la lettre du préfet sur ça
c'est grossi on peut vous dire quelque
chose
lundi matin à 10h
dans le bureau du préfet une fois comme
la Dino déjà elle est venue pour deux
choses
s'explique et s'excuser exactement parce
que j'aimerais bien entendre Nadia
aujourd'hui est en détresse c'est ça
mais il faut pas oublier aujourd'hui que
c'est pas parce que Monsieur et Madame
sont en détresse elle comprend elle
entend elle le respecte mais il faut
aussi lui trouver une solution c'est ce
qu'on dit parce que pour eux aussi
aujourd'hui arriver dans votre émission
en les mettant en mettant en avant
finalement que le préfet pour l'instant
n'a rien fait nous lundi on n'est pas
lundi aujourd'hui on est jeudi on n'est
pas lundi il y a pas de décision
d'expulsion aujourd'hui avec une
autorité de la force publique a été
ordonnée et à côté de ça il y a un appel
qui va passer ici
on a envie que personne on a envie que
personne soit dans la rue
dites ce que vous avez à dire
c'est nous qu'on a souffert c'est nous
qu'on a souffert c'est tout ce que Nadia
vous vous sentez de nous dire quelques
mots bien non
en fait j'étais venu les dire mais vous
avez été coupé dans votre élan
puisque c'est devenu de toute façon
invivable non ça fait deux ans et demi
déjà j'aime cet appartement
bien sûr maintenant qu'est-ce qu'il
aimerait pas
un loyer
900 euros
donc voilà aujourd'hui vous voulez
partir oui bien entendu que je veux
partir surtout après les menaces les
injures et tout ce qui se passe là la
médiatisation moi je tombe des nuls
l'appartement voilà aujourd'hui comment
il est Madame voilà
il faut que tout le monde trouve parce
que d'abord
qu'est-ce qui est sur sa tête avec
ce qu'on espère Nadia le travail elle
paye un loyer elle a une fille on espère
juste que Pierre et Maryse ils
retrouvent leur appartement et la
semaine prochaine et que Nadia ne soit
pas à la rue avec avec sa fille
Christian Quesada est de nouveau en
prison l'ancienne star des douze coups
de midi avait été condamné à 3 ans de
prison pour corruption de mineurs des
tensions et diffusion d'images
pédopornographiques l'affaire Quesada
c'est une affaire de foot on sait que
toi tu es spécialiste tu te présentes
faites entrer la cuisine aujourd'hui il
est retourné en prison il pourrait
rester longtemps mais il pourrait rester
jusqu'à la fin de sa peine c'est-à-dire
un an encore d'accord 112 qui va qui va
le faire il a fait deux ans il était
condamné à 3 ans donc il lui reste un an
à accomplir et je pense que le juge
d'application des peines il n'a pas
remis derrière les barreaux pour
plaisanter il a fait que deux ans de
pression alors deux ans de prison alors
qu'il avait été condamné à trois alors
ça c'est assez classique dans le système
judiciaire français c'est-à-dire qu'en
fait quand un détenu se comporte bien en
prison qu'il voilà qu'il qui suit les
directives qui sont les siennes qui
l'indemnisent les parties civils ben on
peut considérer et il y a un collège
d'ailleurs de magistrats qui se réunit
pour ça il y a la Kabila la capacité
d'être à l'extérieur c'est un personne
qui peut se réinsérer mais après moi je
pense que plus sur des images
pédopornographiques franchement il faut
faire la peine totale je suis après je
sais pas si voilà parce qu'il y en a
beaucoup qui sont malades on a l'extrait
du dossier de l'affaire qui stipule ce
qui est exactement dans les clés USB
dans les disques durs de Christian
Quesada c'est pas des jeunes femmes de
17 ou 18 ans je vous lis ce qui a écrit
exactement des fichiers contenant le
terme ten years donc 10 ans en anglais
il y a par exemple un fichier qui
s'appelle Jessica 10 ans.v i donc c'est
le nom de la vidéo vidéo représentant
une jeune fille en train de faire une
fellation la minorité des sujets semble
flagrante Guillaume hier tu nous a
présenté un document exceptionnel aussi
une lettre de Christian Quesada cette
lettre en fait c'est une lettre qui a
adressée à son ex Sabrina il revient sur
l'affaire il dit qu'il est victime d'un
H&M médiatique il comprend pas pourquoi
enfin il a l'impression qu'on s'acharne
sur son cas et il dit qu'on ne parle pas
d'autre scandales sexuels qui occupent
les médias il a l'impression qu'on ne
parle que de lui il est conscient qu'il
dit qu'il fait beaucoup d'audience il
dit que c'est quelqu'un de bankable il
s'en prend aussi à Jean-Luc Reichmann il
dit qu'il est extrêmement déçu du
comportement de Jean-Luc il parlait
effectivement de sa vie en prison où il
disait qu'il regardait canal quoi
aujourd'hui crushman il dit qu'il l'a
extrêmement déçu qu'il y a des
accusations qui sont pas forcément
fondées et que c'est quelqu'un qui l'a
beaucoup déçu parce qu'il croyait que
c'était un ami
il pensait pas aussi que bien sûr c'est
le monde à l'envers parce que Jean-Luc
Reichmann c'est lui qui s'est fait
berner c'est lui qui s'est affiché à
côté de Christian Quesada pendant des
semaines et des mois Christian Quesada
qui était érigé en espèce de héros et en
fait on apprend que c'est un dangereux
délinquant sexuel et Jean-Luc Reichmann
a pété un câble donc nous nous on se
cache pas non plus c'est vrai qu'on
apprécié vraiment Christian qui s'adapte
quand il venait pas le problème on
l'apprécie avant mais une fois il fait
des trucs pédocrinal
attendez c'est notre pote c'est
Cristiano ça y est c'est fini et puis
mon pote dégage pourquoi tu veux qu'on
défende ou quoi mais il faut lui le
dossier il est immonde il y a déjà des
photos pédopornographiques c'est
terrible il y avait toute une
manipulation une emprise des dialogues
avec des il faisait donc pour rappeler
pour des spectateurs alors il détenait
déjà des photos et des vidéos pédo
pornographiques dont certaines étaient
je le répète des viols d'enfants de
moins de 10 ans évidemment atroce il
entrait en contact sous de fausses
identité avec des jeunes garçons et des
jeunes filles mineures pour ça il
utilisait de faux profils facebook on a
découvert aussi cet après-midi qu'il
avait de faux skyblog qui sont toujours
en ligne d'ailleurs des skyblog de fan
de manga très enfantin il se faisait
passer encore pour une fille et rentrer
en contact avec des jeunes hommes et des
jeunes femmes voilà c'est des procédés
qui sont ignobles et là où il a failli
déraper parce que lui skinny c'est le
fait d'avoir passé à l'acte sauf que on
a la preuve qu'un jour il a donné
rendez-vous sous sa fausse identité donc
sur Facebook à une jeune femme dans un
hôtel près de la gare de Lyon à Paris
pour avoir une relation sexuelle tarifée
avec une star de la télé la star de la
télé c'est lui star des 12 Coups de Midi
il a attendu la jeune fille à l'hôtel la
jeune fille n'est jamais venue et lui il
se cache derrière ça pour dire je ne
suis pas passé à l'acte mais si la jeune
fille était venue qu'est-ce qui serait
passé on ne le sait pas il y a beaucoup
de gens qui se demandent donc pourquoi
il a été réincarcéré selon nos
informations donc il est retourné en
prison déjà pour non-respect de son
suivi socio-judiciaire ce qui veut dire
qu'il a violé une de ses 6 règles
obligations de travail il devait trouver
un emploi un jonction de soins il l'a de
nature psychiatrique et addictologique
obligation d'indemniser la partie civile
il y avait une association de la voix de
l'enfance qui devait payer peut-être
qu'il n'a pas fait interdiction de
contact de quelques manières que ce soit
avec les victimes interdiction de
publier un livre ou une œuvre relative
en infraction et interdiction de quitter
la France de sortir du territoire
national sans l'accord du juge
d'application des peines il
a dit on fait partie de la bande
vous pouvez la difficulté de ce que je
vis voici l'état de l'appart à 18h02
donc ça apparemment c'est pas un lit
pour Redouane c'est une armoire
puisqu'il range ses affaires dessus et
ça ça s'appelle un Clipsal de Redouane
alors la technique est très simple si tu
veux pas que tes doigts fondent en
l'attrapant et ben tu passes par dessus
remarquez que Redouane apparemment est
rentré du foot aujourd'hui hein alors ce
qui est bien avec lui hmm c'est que
vraiment il laisse les saveurs
s'imprégner dans les tissus ça c'est son
petit déj de ce matin en chocolat
évidemment il a une alimentation
équilibrée tes affaires vont aller faire
un joli petit tour je te fais pas un
dessin s'ils sont dans des jolis petits
sacs comme ça parce qu'ils vont aller
rencontrer Madame la poubelle mon grand
allez merci
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas vrai c'est
vraiment un fils de [ __ ]
[Applaudissements]
comment ça va mon chéri
qu'on vit ensemble à peu près quand il a
à Londres avec sa femme quand il est à
Paris viens avec moi et je le connais
depuis bien avant qu'il soit le
l'humoriste à succès l'homme qui remplit
des salles mais ce soir je suis pas là
pour parler de l'artiste je suis là pour
parler de l'homme enfin du port
je te cache pas Redouane que j'en peux
plus de tes merdes qui traînent dans la
maison de la journée en plus toi tu sais
on n'est pas en train de rire là là ce
que tu as vu tu es parti de la part
parce que je te le dis il me dit ouais
c'est bon j'ai le temps et tout moi je
sais que je vais à la mission j'ai très
haut dépêche-toi accélère parce que je
pouvais pas dire pourquoi il me dit ça
va tranquille il commence à faire un
défilé il pose ses affaires par terre
donc maintenant je te le dis c'est
simple soit tu ranges soit moi je
commence à être plutôt côté dans le game
des Colocs la dernière Daniel qui m'a
proposé une petite
mais frérot j'ai pas le temps j'arrive
je vais spectacle foot mais je suis pas
ta femme de ménage depuis
une chronique dans la journée pas le
temps pour faire le ménage la journée
non
il revient du karaté
c'est quoi
par contre je te dis je fais plus jamais
de surprise là c'est vrai pourquoi parce
que je suis d'habitude quand j'arrive on
va rigoler dans salon on tape des barres
et tout ça là je suis arrivé la prod
dis-moi rattrapé va te cacher par la
personne reste tout seul on ferme-toi
j'ai l'impression d'être Gilles Verdez
toi après l'émission les spectacles je
te niquerai ta mère
[Applaudissements]
c'est Daniel Riolo qui a eu des mots
très très durs envers les prisonniers ça
fait énormément parler toute la journée
Daniel Riolo ça réagit encore là-dessus
on va vous montrer ce qu'il a dit vous
allez me dire ce que vous en pensez
Daniel Riolo est-il allé trop loin merci
tout ça il en a rien à signer
dans les prisons
citoyens qui ont fauté qui ont causé du
tort à la société madame non c'est pas
des soleils il a été trop fort il est en
réaction par rapport à ce que lui dit la
la dame qui est en face de lui elle lui
dit c'est des sous-citoyens et lui dit
oui évidemment que non que c'est pas des
sous il y a les peines faut faut prendre
en compte il y a des vols trop loin bah
oui bah il a été trop loin bien sûr
qu'il a été trop loin tu vas en prison
tu vas payer ta peine en prison c'est
mal que tu as fait mais tu n'es pas un
sous citoyen du tout pour autant et
c'est vrai que ça m'étonne que ton mari
et qui est un homme intelligent j'en
suis sûr et puis faire ton mari et puis
faire un amalgame aussi important oui
mais finalement au même niveau un vieux
leurs enfants et quelqu'un qui est voilà
qui récidive sans permis et qui fait de
la prison un enfant fait une bêtise ok
c'est pas un sous-entend mais en fait un
enfant c'est un mot tu vois commun puis
un adulte c'est un mot commun mais le
mot citoyen c'est pas tout à fait un mot
commun c'est un c'est un statut tu
comprends c'est un grade et tu
l'acquières si tu rentres dans c'est un
citoyen de la République donc on
de la République tu peux pas défendre
quand elle te dit est-ce que un
terroriste et un pédocrinel c'est un
souci citoyen toi tu dis NON je dis ce
ne sont pas des monstres mais c'est un
vrai débat
[Applaudissements]
oser des enfants mais qu'est-ce qui
t'arrive Gilles
et Mathieu parle-lui
que j'ai pour toi de côté là je suis
sérieux 2 minutes tu ne peux pas Gilles
comme ça sur un plateau de télé dans 2
millions de personnes dire que un
terroriste ce n'est pas un souci citoyen
voir un sous homme et que c'est
quelqu'un qui faut comprendre enfin
Gilles comprendre
toutes les victimes c'est pas possible
toutes les victimes du Bataclan de tout
citoyen ou un pédocrinel je suis désolé
arrêtez jugé ils ont été condamnés voilà
donc c'est c'est parfait qu'il ne
sortent jamais de prison sans doute mais
quand on me dit ce sont des monstres
l'être humain je suis désolé je suis pas
pour je suis pas pour internet pour les
pédocs criminels et pour les non plus
les familles du 13 novembre qui nous
regardent ce soir mais après non là tu
vas pas loin tu vas un peu loin mais
vous pouvez pas dire ça mais si
condamné je suis pour qu'il sorte jamais
de prison
j'ai dit ce ne sont pas des matchs tu
peux pas dire ça bah voilà un pédophile
est un monstre je suis pas d'accord
j'entends parfaitement pour moi
pédocrinel est un démonstration désolé
excuse-moi et un terroriste aussi désolé
je suis désolé pour moi je suis désolé
moi quand je vois la famille de Nordahl
Lelandais que je vois la maman de de la
petite et le papa et que je peux le dire
pour moi bah c'est c'est je suis désolé
pour moi c'est un monstre internet
d'ailleurs grâce à Internet
pour toi c'est pas un monstre c'est bien
internet dis-le c'est un monstre ou pas
il n'y a pas d'êtres humains pour moi
qui sont des monstres
c'est renier l'état d'êtres humains moi
quand on a tué une petite fille mais oui
et qu'on a violé pour moi je suis désolé
tout ce que vous voulez
ça va est-ce que tu dis tu dis c'est
renier l'état d'être humain mais en viol
où on était un terroriste je suis revenu
l'état d'êtres humains mais il faut pas
être comme eux voilà ce que je dis voilà
ce sont ce sont des gens qui ont commis
des actes horribles mais les les moi
pour moi les pédocrinels et et je peux
plus je peux pas moi avec tout le mal
qu'ils ont fait excuse-moi je les
considère comme des mots si je peux pas
les considérer comme des hommes à mettre
unis pour toi personne n'est un état
pour moi donc voilà les les les
êtres humains qui commettent les pires
atrocités restent des êtres humains
voilà ce que je veux dire voilà voilà
donc c'est pour ça que je suis contre la
peine de morts terribles ce sont des
gens terribles que je déteste mais je ne
leur enlève pas leur état d'êtres
humains
j'en ai rien à [ __ ] je le tue je te le
dis quelqu'un qui tire sur des terrasse
quelqu'un qui tire sur des terrasses sur
des gens pour rien faire qui était
heureux des gens qui ont été dans des
concerts qui ont rien demandé à personne
qui se sont fait canarder comme des
chiens des terroristes qui font des
trucs comme ça des normales Lelandais
des Jonathan Daval qui crame ça face à
sa femme dans la forêt qui lui met des
baskets au pied pour faire croire
qu'elle a été courir moi je te le dis je
le tue le mec j'en vous pouvez
m'insulter sur toute parce que vous
voulez ce mec-là n'a rien à faire sur
Terre avec moi voilà c'est réglé c'est
fait c'est dit voilà
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]